all right, let's do this.
I have a story for you today about the unmitigated
control that large media and social media
platforms have over the content.
You see when it comes to news, no matter what
your intentions are, and I'll explain that
in a second.
It's been months since I've come to you about
a problem on our various platforms because
things have actually been going okay for the
last couple of months.
In fact, this week was one of our best weeks
for the David Pakman show in one sense, but
it also has very quickly become one of the
worst.
CNN filed a completely bogus fraudulent claim
against our coverage of day one of the Trump
impeachment inquiry.
And Facebook has completely shut down our
monetization of videos and I mean a hundred
like literally to $0 million and 0 million
cents with no explanation or prior notice.
I'll explain it to you and I believe you are
going to be shocked and appalled by this.
So we've had a great week going right on Tuesday
our YouTube channel had about a million views,
just that one day it was our best day of the
year in terms of views and normally we get
nine to 11 million views a month.
So one day with a million views is a really
great day.
In fact, our best day of the year, Wednesday
is going great.
We do this six hour live stream of the Trump
impeachment inquiry.
As many of you know, house proceedings are
public domain made available by the house
of representatives, video feeds and by C-SPAN.
So our six hour stream yesterday, which we
spent all day producing, was using the house
feed and the CSPAN feed, no copyright issues.
We're not using content from CNN or Fox news
or anything like that.
We're in the clear, the live stream ends.
We put up the video of the archive of that
six hour stream so people can go back and
check out our commentary.
We do that in addition to our one hour show
and our members show within a few minutes,
I get a notification that CNN has filed a
claim against our video, which is on screen
right now for our television audience and
I say, wait, wait a second.
CNN, we didn't use any CNN video.
We use the feed from the house of representatives
and from Seaspan.
Why on earth is CNN filing a copyright claim
against me for something that has none of
their content.
We spent six hours on this and then CNN takes
it down and we go to YouTube and the videos,
visibility is totally off and of course monetization
is off.
So not only can we not make money from a six
hour stream, we spent all day producing because
of a bogus claim by CNN, but the video's not
even visible.
Not making money would be one thing, but the
entire video was made invisible.
This should be against the law to file fraudulent
copyright claims by the morning.
Now, by this morning, after I appealed it,
emailed people at CNN.
They have removed the claim with no explanation
for why would CNN claim a video that doesn't
have any of their content.
They got away with it.
The video made no money during those key hours
after being published.
Sickening.
But it got even worse.
More than a year ago, I think it was September
of 2018 I was notified by Facebook.
Hey, listen, great news.
You've been uploading your videos to your
Facebook page for a long time.
You can now monetize your videos.
So we were thrilled because we had this great
potential for Facebook video monetization
to be a new revenue source.
We've had YouTube monetization issues.
Now we can monetize on Facebook and maybe
even it out a little bit, but sadly, it didn't
work out so well because we were monetizing
starting in, uh, in 2018.
But sometimes we would make $7 in a month
from monetizing Facebook video or $25 the
next month.
Sadly, it sort of fell flat based on what
we were hoping for, but then suddenly three
months ago, Facebook monetization starts becoming
a real thing.
We actually start making some real money that's
important for the show by monetizing on Facebook
and it's some new revenue potential for us.
What fantastic news, and a few days ago I
go on and I notice we're back down to like
we made a dollar.
We made 50 cents, we made $0 million and 0
million cents on Facebook despite uploading
all of our videos there.
What the hell happened?
They never contacted me about any issue.
We're, we've been uploading our videos, the
videos are getting views, so what's going
on?
I click around our control panel on Facebook
yesterday and notice this big red exclamation
point that says restricted monetization.
The David Pakman show shared content that
was removed by Facebook for going against
community standards on November six 2019 they
claimed that they notified us on that date
of what video violated their standards.
I can assure you we were not notified on Facebook.
I didn't get an email.
No email went to my spam folder.
I tried to look into this.
I tried to contact someone, which Facebook
of course makes impossible to do contact support,
nothing, contact ad team, nothing, contact
anyone, nothing.
The one thing I can do is submit an appeal,
which I do and within hours I get a message
back saying, thank you for submitting an appeal.
After taking a look, we've decided to temporarily
suspend monetization because your page goes
against our policies.
They of course don't tell me anything about
why or what violated their policies or which
page it was.
Of course understand we do an FCC safe show
with no profanity, Gore or anything like that.
Understand the insanity of white supremacists
content is being spread on Facebook.
Mark Zuckerberg is in front of Congress saying,
we don't fact check ads.
We don't do this.
We don't do that.
We are as hands off as we can be and they
shut off monetization for the David Pakman
show and FCC safe show and we're the problem.
We're the ones sharing the problematic content.
Of course, I tried writing right back to Facebook's
bogus letter and I got an automatic replying
saying, Oh, this case is closed.
No one will see your response.
Feel free to file another appeal.
So listen, this is supposed to be when shows
like ours start to flourish.
It's the 365 days before an election.
Historically, these are the best moments for
us.
Now in the immediate, if you have a contact
like a real person at Facebook that you know,
uh, in the ad side, in the monetization side,
in the video side, any real person you can
put me in touch with, it would be more than
greatly appreciated if you did that.
Um, audience wise, we're growing quickly.
We've added like 3000 YouTube subscribers
in the last five days or something like that,
but we are getting hit with this stuff everywhere.
So I'm not gonna make a big pitch.
This is really about the way in which these
platforms are controlling what you ultimately
get to see in support.
But consider grabbing a membership on our
website.
No one can shut that down.
There is no copyright claims.
There's no demonetization.
It's just you sign up@joinpacman.com we pay
a 2.9% fee for processing your payment and
we keep the rest.
Okay.
Very much appreciated.
We have a coupon code.
The code is half 19 it'll save you 50% I don't
care at what price you sign up.
Use the coupon code.
Don't you can save 50% with the coupon code
half 19 this is how we grow our base of support,
you know, in a real grassroots way with small
contributions.
Also, if it's easier for you or if you prefer,
you can pledge on Patrion at patrion.com/david
Pakman show.
This is a very backwards situation and I'm
coming to you laying out the full scope of
it and it is disturbing and it is disappointing.